today on the matt walsh show the kasmic
divide between the two sides in the
culture war was put on full display
during a senate hearing in which a
college professor claimed that men can
get pregnant also j.k rowling officially
disavows me and breaks my heart
in the process i must say she says that
i'm really no different than a trans
activist but today we'll talk about why
that charge could more rightly be
leveled at left-wing feminists like
herself and a disturbing video goes
viral showing two very young children in
the inner city assaulting two police
officers what hope do kids have when
they're raised like that plus john
bolton admits to planning uh coos in
foreign countries while a remarkably
incurious jake tapper sits and nods
along
in our daily cancellation gavin newsom
signs a law that will open gun
manufacturers up to lawsuits there are
all kinds of problems here we'll discuss
today and so much more on the matt wall
show
[Music]
well roe v wade has been overturned and
the battle is now finally leaving dc and
going back to the grassroots no group in
america when it comes to grassroots
fighting over uh the pro-life issue is
better positioned than 40 days for life
their 1 million volunteers hold peaceful
vigils outside abortion facilities and 1
000 cities in fact most of their
volunteers are located in blue state
such as california where the lives of
venice and babies are most threatened
where they're most needed
and that's what they're doing most of
their work many former abortion facility
directors say that these vigils can
cause the abortion no-show rate to
increase to as high as 75 percent which
is a major blow to the abortion business
these peaceful vigils have even led to
many closures of abortion facilities in
america nearly uh half of which we're in
states like uh rather cities like san
francisco chicago and seattle these are
hardly pro-life areas as you may know
but that's again is where 40 days for
life is doing most of their great work
40 years for life is effectively
changing hearts and minds in the
grassroots to end abortion you can check
out their locations podcast and free
magazine at 40daysforlife.com again for
more information on 40 days for life
simply head to 40daysforlife.com
now we reach the end of our jk rowling
saga after being criticized by the left
in the media for calling my film what is
a woman effective though she did so in
the context of criticizing me rowling
finally decided to make it publicly and
abundantly clear that she is not my
friend and we are not allies on twitter
in response to jason whitlock that was
really a response to me marking my first
official
disavowal by a famous person pretty
excited about that she wrote
respectfully i've been facing down the
punch and kill turfs brigade for a while
now and not once have i thought what i
really want is to hand this over to a
man who thinks feminism is one of the
worst things to happen to western
civilization like many women on the left
i despair that so many self-proclaimed
liberals turn a blind eye to the naked
misogyny of the gender identity movement
and the threat it poses to the rights of
women and girls walsh's film undeniably
exposed what many leftists are too
scared to but a shared belief that women
exist as a biological class and water's
wet and the moon's not made of cheese
does not an ally make i believe women
are susceptible to certain harms and
have specific needs that feminism is
necessary to secure and protect our
rights walsh believes feminism is rotten
and his default appears to be
denigrating women with whom he disagrees
he's no more on my side than the shut up
or will bomb you charmers who cloak
their misogyny in a pretty pink and blue
flag
so you're saying that you like my movie
though that's my main takeaway she also
accuses me of denigrating women with
whom i disagree that of course is
ridiculous i denigrate everybody i
disagree with women woman or not just to
be clear and finally she claims that i
believe feminism is rotten and one of
the worst things to happen in western
civilization on that point
i issue no denial whatsoever that is
precisely what i believe the the 60
million dead children that it's already
left in its wake is
probably all the evidence i really need
to support that assertion
but the gender ideology that jk rowling
herself opposes and has fought against
quite bravely and admirably
is itself more evidence of feminism's
fatal flaws
though some left-wing feminists like j.k
rowling have staunchly resisted the
modern manifestations of gender ideology
and its incursions into female spaces
like locker rooms and sports teams and
all that kind of stuff
still feminism has as a whole
utterly failed to halt or even
significantly slow down the advance of
this threat why is that
perhaps rowling and her feminist allies
might want to stop and consider this
question
you know we hear so much from them about
we've been in this fight for years we've
been fighting so
well
why haven't you achieved more than you
have if you've been fighting it for so
long
well what's the obstacle in your way
at the risk of being accused of
mansplaining i'd like to give my own
answer to that question
now since what is a woman came out
feminists have debated amongst
themselves we've talked about this
they've talked they've debated you know
whether they should champion the film
whether they should team up with an
unsavory character like myself for the
sake of defeating the gender ideologues
and ultimately with very few exceptions
they've decided that the answer to both
conundrums is a resounding no
rowling's statement yesterday puts kind
of an exclamation mark
on that uh answer they want nothing to
do with me
they really don't want the help of any
man at all unless he takes an explicitly
subordinate role in the fight and even
then they might not want him
this is one of the reasons why feminism
has failed to stop transgenderism i
think this right here that feminists are
naturally antagonistic towards men they
always have been from the beginning way
back in the so-called first wave
um even back then
antagonistic towards men so they might
complain about you know the way that
women are treated when they speak out
against the trans mob and they might
lament that women they believe are left
alone to face down this horde but
then when any man tries to stand beside
them they can't help but turn on him
they ask for help but then they say to
the man who answers the call oh not you
yuck get away
this is a problem because any true
resistance
any real and effective counter
insurgency against the gender ideology
movement will require the coordinated
efforts of both men and women men have a
totally crucial absolutely crucial role
to play in this fight
women cannot rescue society from this
madness alone and neither can men
this is the beauty
of how we're designed
men and women need each other
our complementary nature means that
we're more powerful working together
than we are apart this is true of men
and women in the context of marriage and
families and it's true i believe on the
societal level
but feminism is inherently antagonistic
towards and competitive with men that's
why feminism is deadly in a marriage
um because
in a marriage you need that
complementary unity but instead through
feminism you get antagonism and and
competition
and it's also why it weakens not
strengthens
the fight for sanity and truth in our
culture
this isn't my assumption by the way i
i've seen this firsthand i have been for
the past month and more
at the center of one of these arguments
among feminists about whether they can
really work hand in hand with a man and
the answer that most of them have come
to is no they can't
well the problems go deeper than that
this is what i really want to talk about
feminists have decided and uh and and
i've been told this explicitly
that i am just one side of the same coin
with the trans activist
as rowling professed i i'm no more her
ally than they are she says i'm just as
much her enemy as you know rabid trans
activist who threatens to kill her and
burn down her house i'm i'm i'm just as
opposed to her as as as they are she
says
and yet if i'm on the same side of if
i'm if i'm on one side of the same coin
with these people
then why is it that i oppose trans
activists not just on the matter of
transgenderism but on literally
everything
i i disagree with the trans activists on
every conceivable issue
any conservative if you're a
conservative this is going to be the
case you disagree with the trans
activist on not just this issue but like
everything you don't agree on anything
so what coin are we sharing exactly
we have nothing at all in common we are
diametrically opposed all the way down
the line on everything we live in
different universes entirely
that's not the case
for jk rowling and the trans activists
it's not the case for any of the
left-wing feminists who seemingly oppose
the trans agenda they all agree with the
trans activists on nearly every issue
except transgenderism so it's the
opposite of our situation
right and and even on transgenderism
many of them agree with the fundamental
proposition even when it comes to that
i'm not sure if this is the case for
rowling specifically but you often hear
the uh so-called gender-critical types
say that well they have no issue with a
man identifying as a woman they'll even
respect his pronouns their problem is
specifically with the male invasion into
private female spaces
very often they go to great lengths to
make it clear they are not denying the
underlying philosophical claims of
transgenderism
but whether they oppose transgenderism
on that level or not the fact is
that left-wing feminists
certainly agree with trans activists on
most other major issues that's why the
two groups can march hand-in-hand at the
pro-abortion rally uh at the gay pride
rally at almost any other rally
this is because the trans activists and
the feminists actually share an
overarching world view their fundamental
premise is the same
why do you think planned parenthood has
gotten into the gender transition game
it was not only a savvy business move
for a company that stands to lose
millions from all the babies that will
no longer be allowed to kill
but also a natural evolution
transgenderism itself is a is a natural
evolution from feminism
feminism came first
setting the stage and then
transgenderism gender theories sprang
out of the same milieu
these are not two separate and distinct
things but rather two branches on the
same tree deeply intertwined and uh and
associated with connected with each
other
and that's stepman writer for the
federalists and other places explained
this i thought pretty succinctly on
twitter she said
i respect my many feminist allies in
this fight but this is fundamentally
true transgenderism is not an aberration
away from the fundamental assumptions of
feminism but their logical conclusion
the central tenet of all waves of
feminism has been that the differences
between the sexes are not biological but
socially constructed that your sex
should not matter with regard to any
important decisions in your life or how
society interacts with you but this is
and always has been a lie the
differences in our brains and
corresponding psychology have just as
much scientific backing as the
differences in upper body strength only
difference is one threatens the premise
of feminism and the other doesn't but
they both come with societal and
personal implications
i think that pretty much summarizes
feminism has preached from the beginning
that the physical differences between
the sexes are largely unimportant and
irrelevant
while a stepman points out uh outright
denying the existence of some of the
differences
it's only a short distance from that
to the trans act of his claim that all
of the differences are effectively
non-existent
sex is a social construct it's a
performance it's a thing that an
individual chooses to participate in or
not
now that idea is absurd but it's absurd
in the same way that feminism is absurd
feminism and transgenderism are our
cousins at the very least but probably
more like twins in the midst of a
sibling rivalry
they have more in common too both gender
ideology and feminism are hostile to the
nuclear family both see it as an
inherently oppressive and patriarchal
structure which has to be demolished
this again has been feminism's professed
intention from the beginning of the
movement all the way back down to the
first wave the trans activists are
explicit about this as well
but you know and so when they talk about
the evils of the family
they are indistinguishable from each
other
the two once again are looking through
the same lens
but most of all they have this in common
this is what really matters
they are relativists
all leftists are relativists in fact you
could stop using the word leftist and
simply call them relativists because
relativism is the gospel they all share
it's the thing that binds them together
it's the creed they all profess
a left-wing feminist may believe that
there's an objective physical truth
about the world which we can all know
but if she's on the left then she
certainly at least believes
that moral truth is relative
we're not subject to any ultimate moral
order we construct our morality for
ourselves
one cannot be pro-abortion without
having this view
the view that there is no objective or
fundamental moral truth
so once again the trans activist
takes this to its logical conclusion if
there is no objective moral truth
then who is to say
that there's any objective truth at all
if i can create my own moral universe
then why can't i create my own physical
universe
the trans activist takes the left-wing
feminist up on her own word he follows
her premise all the way down to the
bottom to its core
and she looks and sees what it looks
like and and she recoils in horror at
the results
but she doesn't realize she's looking in
the mirror
it is feminism and transgenderism which
are two sides of the same coin
that's why the feminist can't take a
swing at gender ideology without hitting
herself in the process
and this is why she ultimately fails in
the fight
and that's why
they cannot accept me or any of us as
allies
but at least or jk rowling is concerned
if we don't have that in common we will
always still share a bond as
best-selling children's authors
that's one thing they can't take away
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
did you know that one out of three
americans regularly suffer from nausea
every time i watch the news i get
nauseous you know and every time i
travel in a car as you know i get
nauseous we
especially the 20 hours we did to go on
vacation i was especially nauseous and
that's why i made sure that i had my
trusty relief band i never leave home
without it that's why people call me mr
relief band because i always have it
with me that's what they call me it's
true relief ben is the number one fda
cleared anti-nausea wristband that's
been clinically proven to quickly
relieve and effectively prevent nausea
and vomiting associated with motion
sickness anxiety migraines hangovers
morning sickness chemotherapy and so
much more how it works is relief band
stimulates a nerve in the wrist that
travels to the part of the brain that
controls nausea then it blocks the
signal that your brain is sending to
your stomach telling you that you're
sick it's like the name says it's
legitimately a band you wear on your
wrist to give you relief from nausea and
you can change the intensity depending
on how you're feeling to make it
stronger or weaker it's really that
simple so if you're finally taking that
summer trip or you're just nauseous from
everything going on in the world i've
got good news for you right now you can
join the over 100 000 relief band users
with an exclusive offer just for my
listeners if you go to reliefband.com
and use promo code wall she'll receive
20 off plus free shipping and no
questions asked 30 day money back
guarantee remember it's better to
have a relief band and not need it than
to need it and not have it so head to
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com and use our
promo code walsh for 20 off plus free
shipping
now before we get into the headlines uh
i got to tell you this is the most
important headline in fact we have a new
item now available in the daily wire
shop and go to dailywire.com
shop and go to our store there we've got
all kinds of uh
great products and i know i'm a little
bit biased but i think honestly
uh
frankly i think we do have the best
store at the daily wire i mean all the
other other ones are great but ours is
the best because of items like this so
this is the newest thing
this is um
the uh our shirt where you can profess
your pride
in being a believer in space aliens with
the my truth is out there
shirt
because
as i've as i've said many times i don't
know if aliens exist in the universe
but they exist in my heart
they are my truth and i know that my
truth is out there in the form of a
of an alien with uh
that beautiful wig on as well so go to
dailywire.com and get those shirts now
speaking of martians from outer space
this is from the daily wire it says in a
contentious exchange in which an
abortion rights advocate and law
professor acted patronizingly towards
missouri gop senator josh hawley who
asked whether her phrase people with a
capacity for pregnancy simply meant
women the professor accused him of being
transphobic this is university of
california berkeley law professor kiara
bridges and she appeared at a hearing
held by the senate judiciary committee
to examine legal concerns following the
supreme court decision that overturned
roe v wade and rather than describing
the exchange i think it's better if we
just watch it here it is
professor bridges you said several times
you've used a phrase i want to make sure
i understand what you mean by it you've
referred to people with a capacity for
pregnancy
would that be women
many women cis women have the capacity
for pregnancy many cis women do not have
the capacity for pregnancy
there are also trans men who are capable
of pregnancy as well as non-binary
people who are capable of pregnancy so
this isn't really a women's rights issue
it's uh we can recognize that this
impacts women while also recognizing
that it impacts other groups those
things are not mutually exclusive
senator hawley so your view is is that
the core of this this right then is
about what
so um i want to recognize that your line
of questioning
is transphobic
and it opens up trans people to violence
by not recognizing that wow you're
saying that i'm opening up people to
violence by asking whether or not women
are the folks who can have pregnancies
so i'm one i want to note that one out
of five transgender
persons have attempted suicide so i
think it's important because of my line
of questioning so we can't talk about it
because denying that trans people exist
and pretending not to know that they
exist i'm denying that trans people
exist by asking are you if you're are
you about women are you having
pregnancies do you believe that the uh
men can get pregnant
no i don't think so so you're not gonna
trans people like this and that leads to
violence is this how you run your
classroom are students allowed to
question you or are they also treated
like this or are you interested
opening up people to violence we have a
good time in my class you should join me
you might learn a lot wow i would learn
a lot i've learned a lot i know it's
exciting absolutely extraordinary
okay so to use a phrase that i
absolutely hate uh there's a lot to
unpack here first we again get this
straw man of uh you deny trans people
exist
now we have to
we have to answer this
charge i think in a in a
in a specific in a particular way
because
in one sense it's true that we do deny
that we deny
the logical and scientific validity
of transgenderism as a concept or at
least we should
so
in effect we deny that quote trans
people exist as a category we don't
though deny the existence of people who
identify as trans okay that's the
distinction that's the nuance and the
left though when they say you deny trans
people exist they're trying to conflate
these two things they're trying to erase
this distinction
right but it's also a clever trick
because it provokes conservatives
oftentimes to say and i i've maybe been
guilty of this in the past
and it's just a when you're when you're
when you're not being um
you know when you're being lazy in the
way that you in the way that you speak
you might you might respond and say no
we don't deny that trans people exist
and just leave it at that
and if you say that though no no of
course trans people exist then it sounds
like you're endorsing the whole concept
like the idea that a person can be
trans in that the the claims they're
making about the world are actually true
so that's
you know it's
that is a
a self-identification that people have
made about themselves
claiming to be transgender that is sort
of beyond gender to exist in this other
category there are people who have made
this claim about themselves there are
there are men out there males who make
the claim that they're women those males
do exist the claims they're making
though are not true
um but there are a few other points to
make based on this exchange
another is that is that this woman is we
always have to
note this is a is a law professor okay
she is a and yeah she's at berkeley
but even so she's a highly educated
academic in charge of informing and
teaching and tutoring young minds people
spend exorbitant amounts of money to
send their children to this person
and even conservative parents do this
now there might not be a lot of
conservative parents sending their kids
off to to berkeley but
conservative parents spend thousands of
dollars plunging themselves and their
children into years of debt for the
privilege of being brainwashed by this
fruitcake or fruitcakes just like her
because what we have to understand is
that she is not at all an aberration
nearly every college professor in the
university system is just like that
nearly every single one
there are very few who at least publicly
would disagree with anything you just
heard that woman say
almost all of them have bought in
in a public-facing way at least that's
all that really matters because if they
know better but in their heads but you
know
but they're still preaching and teaching
this kind of madness then that's all
that matters
i mean at this point i really see no
difference between sending your kid to a
university and sending them off to some
sort of like suicide cult in the jungle
somewhere to be indoctrinated i don't
really see a difference
it's it's madness
with few exceptions like there are a few
colleges out there that are still safe
and when i say safe i mean colleges that
are actually interested in educating
people
a few of them the vast majority have
gotten out of the education game they
got out of it a long time ago
and now what they are educating children
in and not not even children young
adults
the education they're providing is
indoctrination into
the most insane
worldview the world has ever seen
um also note how she says
well when you when you say this or when
you ask this question it's not even a
statement that hollow the josh hawley
was making as he points out he was
asking a question not even making a
statement but when you ask this question
she says you're opening trans people up
to violence
and then
he asks for clarification
and what does she say
she doesn't she doesn't point to the
mythological
epidemic of hate crimes against trans
people that isn't really happening
instead she says suicide that's what she
points to
so
when she says violence when you're
you're provoking violence against trans
people what she's saying is
you're provoking trans people to commit
violence against themselves because of
what you're saying
what she's saying is trans people have
guns to their own heads
and if you don't stop saying what you're
saying right now they're gonna pull the
trigger
this is the emotional blackmail that we
get
and of course it's not based in reality
whatsoever even if it was like
our obligation is to speak the truth
and
uh you cannot sacrifice the truth for
any reason whatsoever
and that's where we start
but it also just happens that the claim
she's making is not true
you know or at least the implication
insinuation that if you if the trans
people are committing suicide because
people are questioning their identity
as we have seen as we went over and what
is a woman in the film scott nugent
talked about
uh trans people are the most suicidal 10
years after transition so what that
means is that you can
you can give them all of the affirmation
in the world it doesn't do anything
to solve the suicide problem in fact
arguably the statistics show it makes it
worse
and we should see that now i mean i i
think the left would at least admit
or would uh would concede
that today
you know
on this day in the year 2022
we are a far more
affirming culture
of transgenderism than we were
30 years ago
yet is the trans suicide rate
lower today than it was 30 years ago
no it's higher
that doesn't make any sense if
affirmation is what prevents this the
suicide epidemic from happening
and then of course we have evidenced
again illustrated for all to see the the
two universes as we talked about in the
opening the chasmic divide
two sides that cannot be reconciled
you hear the professor the way she she
says and she says
are you claiming
that men can't get pregnant this is
supposed to be a gotcha from her
against senator holly
what are you actually saying that men
can't get pregnant uh yeah that's what
i'm saying
yeah i'm saying the thing that every
single person on earth would also say up
until 12 seconds ago and even now
in the last 12 seconds the vast majority
of people would still say this yeah
that's what i'm saying now perhaps she
doesn't believe what she's saying there
are a lot of uh
thoroughly unimpressive lackluster
people in academia and beyond who've
made careers and names for themselves by
repeating the nonsensical tripe that's
been scripted for them so it could just
be that
or maybe she does believe it
as i said it doesn't make a difference
really one way or another
and then you see the left's reaction
this is another another litmus test
moment
because that clip has gone viral
on the left and the right
with people on the left if you go to
social media saying oh that looks this
professor she she demolished josh hawley
embarrassed him humiliated him
these are people who watch the exchange
you just watched
with a woman claiming that men can get
pregnant
and they come away not only agreeing
with her but believing that she totally
dismantled and humiliated the other
party in the conversation
we're into universes like there is i'm
sorry to say as but as i have been
saying for years there is no reconciling
this there is no
common ground in between it doesn't
exist
the only unity the only reconciliation
is for
one universe to be destroyed
right this is like for the two universes
to collide
and and one to be destroyed
that's the only
unity here
and the left has made that clear
yes you can be united with us we would
love to be united with you
um but you have to
renounce everything that you believe beg
for our forgiveness
give up on on your entire worldview
um
all your most deeply held beliefs and
then come over to us in our universe and
then we can be united although even then
not really
because you're still going to take a
subservient role
the fact that you ever disagree with us
at all we're not going to ever forget
about that or really forgive or or
forgive you for it
but we will allow you
you know we'll allow you to be part of
the team maybe as a water boy or
something
that's the message
all right
and and our message has to be
similar in return
the only difference is that we have
grace and forgiveness
but we have a similar message in that no
we what we're saying to the other side
is no we we cannot come over to you
you need to abandon
this delusional insane worldview that
you have
and come back into the light and the
truth that's the only way that we could
be united with you we cannot come to you
you have to come to us
all right let's go to this daily wire
has this report it says a disturbing
video reportedly taken in saint paul
minnesota last week shows diaper black
toddlers cursing and attacking police
officers
alphanews.org posted the video online
said it was shot as the officers
attempted to execute a search warrant
for a murder suspect two toddlers can be
seen punching kicking cursing throwing
rocks at the officers
you can also hear
someone else appears to be an adult
who's exhorting the children egging them
on and taunting the black officers
we have that footage let's play that now
um
[Music]
hello
[Music]
that's just an incredibly sad video for
one thing that one kid is uh
you know kid could be more than five
years old
and what what hope does that child have
in life really
and uh is it
i'm not gonna say there's no hope i mean
there's hope for everybody certainly
pray for that child
but
that is a kid at an extreme disadvantage
in
life and why is that
because what we're told you know what
the left would say you watch that video
and they would say well those kids there
those they're victims of systemic races
they would actually agree with me that
the child is of course at an extreme
disadvantage um
but they would say it's because of it's
because the
the the system systemic racism
is that what you see in the video though
the problems in the inner city
are they due to systemic racism and
police brutality
or are they largely due to what we just
saw what we just witnessed which is the
obliterated family structure
negligent or non-existent parenting
or sometimes parenting that is uh
that's worse than non-existent
where the parent is present
but actively encouraging their children
to engage in behavior like that
it's kind of like i guess we would call
that anti-parenting
and it also shows the totally impossible
situation that police are in
when you've got toddlers acting like
that
i mean they're being trained from a
young age to assault police officers
um what hope is there for the police
in these communities
and the difficulties that police face
all of the the anti-police sentiment
as we
transition into the next story here that
i want to make sure i mention
all of that is all the more reason to
hold the cops and you have all the
accountable
okay because you have to contain the rot
in uvalde don't cover it up
don't shield these cops from
accountability
if you do all of the anti-police stuff
only gets a thousand times worse
so here's the latest there in uvalde
uh this is the new york post it says
cops responding to the ivaldi texas
school shooting ran away from gunshots
while 19 children and two teachers were
left to die in their classrooms
according to new footage of the
horrifying attack published tuesday this
footage is out there which i'm not gonna
play it but you can you can go and find
it if you want to
um
and one of the reasons i'm not going to
play there's not a lot of
there's not a lot to be to be learned
from it from the audio
and it mostly just shows it's a long
video and it mostly just shows these
officers
standing around in the hallway
the disturbing video first obtained by
the austin american statesman
shows how police officers dilly-dallied
in the hallway of rob elementary school
instead of charging toward 18 year old
gunman salvador ramos as he
systematically slaughtered 21 people on
may 24th the 77-minute clip
shows officers rushing into the school
just minutes after 18 year old ramos
began his rampage but rather than
confront him they stop and linger
with one cabinet helmet and vest even
seen using a wall mounted hand sanitizer
and checking his phone that's probably
the most shocking thing from this video
is towards the end of it these guys have
just been standing around the hallway
and he kind of saunters over to this
hand sanitizer
thing that's on the wall and sanitizes
his hands while he's there and i've even
heard some people trying to make excuses
for that saying well he might be
sanitizing his hands because he knows
he's going to have to administer medical
aid and so he's that's why he's doing
that except that he sanitizes his hands
and then just continues to stand there
doing nothing
okay he doesn't do that and then run
into administer medical aid
there were a lot of kids who needed
medical aid and died because they didn't
get it
but the officers were just standing
there
maybe i should correct myself they don't
just stand the entire video in the first
part of the video you see them run away
because first they
they enter their they are hot on the
heels of the the shooter they make it
into the building a couple minutes after
him
they're going towards the classroom then
you hear gunshots and you see
these cowards
running for their lives
and then they spend most of the time
cowering behind you know in a in a
hallway in an adjacent hallway
um
i said there's not a lot you can learn
from the audio in the video there is
there is one thing though an important
thing
is that several minutes into this you
hear more gunshots coming from the
classroom being fired by the shooter
he's not firing at the police officers
so we can of course assume that that is
him killing more children
and this proves what was already pretty
evident but i think now it proves it
that
because those officers didn't go in more
children were killed
it's not as though as we were originally
told that the story kept changing of
course but one of the early versions of
the story is that by the time the
officers got there um all of the damage
had been done and he'd already
he'd already slaughtered all these
people
and the shooting was over and now is
more of like a hostage situation and so
that's why they were waiting around over
there or they couldn't get in we were
also told that they couldn't get in the
door because it was locked
so it turns out the door was not locked
it was unlocked the entire time they
were cowering on the other side of an
unlocked door
but we also know now that he continued
slaughtering kids while those officers
heavily armed
whatever it is 19 of them ballistic
shields heavily armed are just standing
on the other side of the door
as kids are being slaughtered
really all these officers should be put
in prison until they rot that's what
should happen it's not going to happen
so at the very least
um all of their names need to be
released
at the very least
like we have the right to know who these
people are
and if that's all the accountability
that happens at least it's something
there's another point to make here also
which is that
you know after uvaldi what we've heard
from the gun grabbing crowd is well you
see
the good guy with a gun
that doesn't work that plan doesn't work
no there's no problem with the plan
the good guys with guns were right there
they could have saved countless lives
they were right there
they they but they they they didn't do
anything they just stood there
they were not good guys that's that's
the problem it's not it's the issue not
with a gun is that they were not you
need good guys with guns that means men
people who are courageous
and willing to do the right thing there
are a lot of people like that in society
unfortunately um
none of them were in that hallway that
day
all right let's go uh to this john
bolton was on cnn after another january
6th hearing and one moment in this
conversation really stood out listen to
this
it's also a mistake as some people have
said including on the committee the
commentators that somehow this was a
carefully planned coup d'etat aimed at
the constitution that's not the way
donald trump does things it's rambling
from one half vast idea to another one
plan that falls through and another
comes up that that's what he was doing
as i say none of it defensible but you
have to understand the nature of what
the problem of donald trump is he's to
use a star wars metaphor a disturbance
in the force and it's not an attack on
our democracy it's donald trump looking
out for donald trump it's a once in a
lifetime occurrence i don't know that i
agree with you to be to be uh fair with
all due respect uh one doesn't have to
be
brilliant to attempt a coup uh i
disagree with that as somebody who has
helped plan coup d'etat yeah not here
but you know other places uh it takes a
lot of work and that's not what he did
it was just stumbling around from one
idea to another ultimately he did
unleash the rioters at the capitol as to
that there's no doubt but not overthrow
the constitution to buy more time to
throw the matter back to the states to
try and redo the issue and if you don't
believe that you're going to overreact
that is a really amazing video just the
total lack of curiosity on the part of
jake tapper who's allegedly a journalist
you've got john bolton who announces oh
i've i've planned uh coups i've done
that many times
there's no follow-up from jake tapper
saying uh when did you do that
which coups were that exactly you tell
me more about that
this is you know we know the government
does this
orchestrates coups and and insurrections
even as they claim that there are
attacks on democracy in this country
they organize those sorts of things and
instigate them and fund them and carry
them out in other countries so we we
knew that the government did that but
they don't usually admit it you know you
usually have government officials not
only admitting it but bragging about it
because he's what he's saying what he's
responding to is is the claim
that you don't have to be brilliant to
organize a coup and he's saying no you
do because i've done it and i'm
brilliant
i i'm great at doing coups because i'm
such a brilliant guy
jake dabber asks no follow-up instead he
says
actually he says he says yeah
you know i've planned cuz yeah
continue continue to your next point we
don't need to linger on that at all
my god
all right one other thing before we get
to the comment section um
a long story in the wall street journal
which
taylor lorenz actually tweeted and she
tweeted with the caption
the ban air conditioning movement is
growing
headline employers beware people who
once put up with thermostats
set to deep freeze now want the kind of
climate control they had working from
home
the article goes on public health nurse
becky graham brought a suitcase of
winter clothes from minnesota to a
springtime conference in atlanta where
it was 80 degrees miss graham said i
have a tank top a long sleeve shirt and
a sweatshirt on and jeans and i'm still
cold
she lent what layers she could spare to
those who arrived ill suited for the
deep chill of conference room conference
rooms in atlanta's convention center for
two years people who work from home
could fine-tune thermostats to their
liking as they head back to the offices
many are lamenting the loss of control
over their workday environment
i got to tell you this article goes on
for pages with uh all of these sob
stories from people
complaining that it's too cold in the
office now they have to go back to work
because they've been working from home
now they gotta go back to work and it's
cold because of the evil air
conditionings
now the the article doesn't actually
call for banning air conditioning
but it is part of this anti-air
conditioning genre that exists i have to
tell you the anti-ac movement
i think we've talked about this before i
don't think we talked about it enough
though it is barbaric really it is pure
barbarism
every summer we have to go through this
so let's just review it again
first of all if you want to ban ac
if you are anti-air conditioning
to any extent at all
then you are anti-human
because air conditioning is without
exaggeration one of the top five maybe
top three human inventions of all time
it competes with the printing press i
think it may actually come before it
it's hard to think of any individual
innovation and you could challenge me on
this
any individual invention or innovation
that has so helped to increase human
health happiness and well-being more
than air conditioning has
before the world had air conditioning
you know what people did they just
suffered in the heat okay it was hot and
sticky and it smelled and it was gross
and it was sweaty and it was filthy and
it was horrible much like los angeles is
now but even in los angeles you can
still go inside and enjoy the air
conditioning
um before the looters come in or someone
comes in and robs you at gunpoint but
before then you can have the air
conditioning it saves lives
this is why we owe it to air
conditioning and to our forefathers who
gave us this great blessing
to blast it as much as we can in the
summer i mean just blast it it should be
it should be warmer in your refrigerator
than it is in your house and in your
office if you're too cold wear a sweater
because we always have to remind people
if you're too cold you can always put on
more layers you can wear a whole snow
suit if you want you know if you build
an igloo in the office if you need to
you can do anything
but if you're hot there's only so many
layers you can take off before hr gets
involved before the police get involved
um
so i'm glad we could establish this once
again now let's get to our
comment section
[Music]
many of us spend more time every day in
our office chair than in our cars or
beds that's why it's so important to
invest in the right chair to spend those
hours with the right level of support
and comfort to get the most productivity
out of your day extra has made my time
at my desk not only more productive but
it's honestly my favorite place to sit
for any reason i don't have my i just
have a a crappy wooden chair that i'm
sitting in right now i couldn't bring my
ex chair on our trip i tried to fit in
the car my wife so i said we don't need
any other luggage luggage i'm just going
to bring my ex chair she said that's
crazy so unfortunately i'm going without
it but uh the reason i love the x chair
is that it has the patented dynamic
variable lumbar or dvl support that
offers customized support but next year
could also give you a massage it can
heat up or cool down it's got all those
features and now thanks to x chairs new
uh fs360 armrests i could even adjust my
armrest to the perfect position that i
need all these unique x-chair features
help the hours on my desk fly by in
complete comfort that's why i love my
x-chair and i miss it
terribly due to popular demand x-chair
has extended their sale through july 15.
so you can buy now before prices
increase again go to xchairwalsh.com now
that's the letter x chair walsh.com or
call one eight four four four x chair
xjr is a complete 30-day money-back
guarantee for complete comfort and you
can finance your purchase for as little
as 30 bucks a month
xchairwalsh.com now
zach says when matt was showing the
picture of the webb telescope i'm
shocked he didn't end that segment by
saying this picture shows how much is in
the universe and this is more proof that
there have to be aliens somewhere out
there in the universe missed a perfect
opportunity to drop more pro alien
propaganda
i did i didn't miss that i did point
that out didn't i i'm pretty sure i i
didn't miss that opportunity i never
would miss that opportunity i'm a big
alien supporter as you know which is why
we have these new shirts which are
available at the daily wire store
my truth is out there go get yours now
um
zazz razzmatazz says behind every victim
there's a dude in a dress saying he's
the bigger victim
could not have said better myself
uh another comment says matt making fun
of how jill biden pronounces bodegas
while simultaneously pronouncing unitos
as united's well how am i supposed to
pronounce it
how is it
unidos unidos is that what it's supposed
to be look i'm allowed to mispronounce
spanish words because i speak english
number one but also because um i'm not
trying to pander to the hispanic
community so i'm allowed this is even
though i'm in this glass house of
mispronouncing i can still throw stones
at least at dr joe biden phd because she
commits this uh this
grammatical crime while trying to
pander to the hispanic community if
you're going to do that
then i think you have to be held to
certain standards of pronunciation
another comment says saying spanish
people are tacos is like saying matt is
a box of lucky charms which is would be
especially offensive actually as lucky
charms
are the worst cereal at least tacos are
delicious you know
uh freeze 3207 says as a black man who
enjoy who actually enjoyed friends the
tv show
i never once thought about the lack of
black people until they just now
mentioned it well that's because almost
nobody thought about that in the 90s
okay al sharpton was thinking about that
kind of thing in the 90s jesse jackson
was very few other people were
uh we
we were
kind of living our lives especially if
you were i don't know how old you are
but if you were kid in the 90s it's not
something you thought about very much
liam says
hey matt quick question regarding the
telescope capturing stars and galaxies
billions of light years away it takes
millions and billions of years for light
to reach us from that far away does that
mean that those stars and galaxies have
existed for billions of years how does
that fit in with the creation account in
genesis i've always believed in the
literal interpretation of seven days but
this seems to lean more towards the day
age theory thanks for your time spg for
life
um yeah well the the problem of distant
starlight is i think
one of the greatest problems that the
people who take the literal
interpretation of genesis face
um i think there are a lot of problems
for that interpretation
but the fact that these stars exist
and are billions and trillions of miles
away and we can see them
is scientific proof that they've been
that the universe is billions of years
old because if it wasn't we wouldn't be
able to see them the light would not
have made it to us by now
um
as far as that goes look uh
the the account genesis talks about
days uses the word days
before there's even a sun
which appears in the account
right so so we know that it can't be a
literal 24-hour day
because the literal 24-hour day is
defined by earth's relationship to the
sun that's what a day is
um if there's no sun then our conception
of a day has has to be completely
altered a day is a relative thing and
all the days are
a day could be
two hours or 200 years depending on
where you live and um and uh in the
universe i mean depending on where you
live in the universe where your planet
is and all that so that's how these
things are defined so if we're talking
about a day
before we have a sun
then uh it's obvious that we mean day in
some other sense not in the literal 24
hours
all right
and finally lauren says
matt who's doing your makeup while being
incognito
well lauren you know those are questions
we don't ask
you know that you get banned from the
show for asking that question
and also the answer is my wife and we
won't speak of it again
pride month is
sadly over all the corporations have
taken down their rainbow logos and
stored them in the garage until next
year and while their celebration might
have ended what is a woman is still one
of the most popular movies at home on
rotten tomatoes
so we're still celebrating our own sort
of pride month because i am very proud
of this film at least it's got a 97
audience score from well over 5 000
ratings
still getting talked about people are
still watching it even if mainstream
reviewers still won't touch it daily
wire is known for creating fearless
documentaries and other pieces of
content like what is a woman that's not
all you get if you subscribe to daily
wire plus you'll get everything you love
about the daily wire and so much more as
a member you get exclusive access to new
shows and content from jordan peterson
plus the entire prageru uh library plus
original movies and documentaries plus
animated and live action kids content
coming soon you're getting all of that
we're building the future you want to
see you got to join us though we need
your help head to dailywireplus.com and
become a member that's
dailywireplus.com today now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
for our daily cancellation we head west
to the great
mystical fountain which pours forth with
an endless stream of cancelable people
and things and people who look like
things i'm speaking of course about
california where governor gavin newsom
has proudly announced a new law that
he's very excited about the daily wire
reports democratic governor of
california governors and recently
recently
put several gun measures into law
including one on tuesday that would
allow lawsuits to be filed against gun
makers the law
ab-1594 creates a firearm industry
standard of conduct including the
requirement to establish implement and
enforce reasonable controls and take
reasonable precautions to ensure that
the firearm industry uh does not sell
distribute or provide a firearm related
product to a downstream distributor or
retailer of firearm related products who
fails to establish implement and enforce
reasonable controls that's very clear
clear if a member of the gun industry
fails to comply with these standards and
others set forth on the bill they may be
sued newsome said in a statement in part
nearly every industry is held liable
when people are hurt or killed by their
products guns should be no different and
we have more here from the governor
explaining this new piece of legislation
listen to this
well it's well known that nearly every
industry is held to account when their
products cause harm or injury well
except one the gun industry the gun
lobby well it spent millions and
millions of dollars buying off
politicians to shield themselves from
any liability today california is going
to change that they can no longer hide
from the mass destruction that they have
caused i'll be signing a bill that will
allow californians to sue irresponsible
gun manufacturers and distributors if
you've been hurt or a family member is a
victim of gun violence
you can now go to court
and hold the makers of these deadly
weapons accountable our kids families
and communities deserve to live without
the worry of gun violence and with
assembly member ting's bill gun makers
will finally be held to account for
their role in this crisis
well this is all it should go without
saying uh complete nonsense
in fact no industry is held to account
if their products are misused or used
illegally
no industry is required to put
safeguards in place which prevent
individuals from exercising free will
while they use the product
no industry is held to that rather
impossible standard newsome doesn't want
the gun industry to be treated like any
other industry but rather he wants it to
be set apart from all other industries
and how it's treated
it's not difficult to think of examples
that disprove newsom's point here
for instance
you can't sue the car manufacturer if
somebody runs a red light and t-bones
you
you can't sue uh the car manufacturer or
the alcohol company if the person who
t-boned you was drunk behind the wheel
you you can't sue black and decker if
somebody hits you over the head with a
hammer you can't sue whatever company
made the knife that someone plunged into
your chest you can't sue the toaster
company if you electrocute yourself
because you were trying to make toast
while taking a bath you can't sue uh you
can't purchase a helium balloon and then
sue party city after you jump off a
building and break your back because you
thought the balloon would help you float
safely to the ground here's when you can
sue
if you get injured while driving because
your car
randomly blows up or the wheels fall off
if you get electrocuted by the toaster
while using it properly outside of the
bathtub if you get hit in the head with
a hammer because the head of the hammer
flew off while you were trying to nail
something you might have a chance of
winning a lawsuit against somebody
because of that
if party city markets its balloons as
suitable parachute substitutes then you
certainly could sue for your broken back
and would probably win millions
if a product is used properly
and in accordance with the law
and during that proper and supposedly
safe usage it hurts or kills somebody
that's when you consume
if if if a product is marketed a certain
way
and the marketing says hey you should
use the product to do this
and then you buy it and do that and you
uh because you did what the marketing
said
you hurt yourself or somebody else once
again lawsuits will will come because of
that
and you can sue gun manufacturers in
those circumstances already
you can sue gun manufacturers for a
range of things in fact
the left claims that gun manufacturers
are totally exempt from all legal action
but that would come as news to the
families of nine sandy hook victims who
sued remington and won 73 million
dollars just a couple years ago
but in that case they were suing over
remington's marketing practices claiming
that it was marketing its product in a
dangerous and reckless and irresponsible
way now whatever you think of their
claim the point remains that you can
already sue gun manufacturers for all of
the same reasons that you can sue any
other type of company
for another example a gun manufacturer
was sued back in 2014
when one of their hunting rifles
exploded injuring a man's hand and
burning his face
the gun was being used properly and
legally in accordance with all the laws
and regulations and keeping with gun
safety protocols and it certainly was
not marketed as the um as the exploding
type of gun and so and but it exploded
and it hurt someone so the manufacturer
was sued
in california
they want to single gun manufacturers
out make a special case out of them
by making them the only companies that
can be sued for harm done when their
product is intentionally and illegally
misused
and and you know you can pretty much
hurt yourself or somebody else with
almost any object or product if you want
if you are determined to misuse it
which is why those kinds of lawsuits in
any other case would not be allowed
now if this law is allowed to stand
which it probably won't be it'll almost
certainly be blocked in court it would
bankrupt the gun industry
and that of course is the point
now the left knows they can't uh like
abolish the second amendment so instead
they look for these kinds of in-run
maneuvers
if they can't get rid of your legal
right to purchase a gun they can just
try to get rid of your ability to
purchase a gun because there are no guns
available because they've bankrupted all
the gun distributors
that's what they'll try to do anyway
they're not going to succeed because the
assault on gun rights is the one area of
the culture war where the left has
consistently failed
that's what makes them so angry
and so desperate
especially gavin newsom who is today
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel vadowsky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomlin our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show a berkeley
professor goes viral for lecturing
senator josh halley on men having babies
they examine a shocking tape of a
toddler cursing out a police officer in
minnesota and joe biden's inflation is
getting worse and worse that's today on
the venture bureau give it a listen
you